we live in this super fast-paced culture  you got to get your hustle on you got to  like work 24 hours a day and if you're  not being productive in every moment of  your waking existence then you're  wasting time and you're falling behind  and with that comes a deep  prioritization of sleep sleep is for  slackers right  and nothing could be further from the  truth  i know that i can't perform at my very  best unless i get eight hours of sleep  and it's not just the amount of time  that i sleep it's the quality of that  sleep it's the caliber of that sleep it  is my opinion that everybody should be  doing everything they can to enhance  that quality of their evening hours and  i found that by sleeping in a tent  it's almost like this  hack towards improving the caliber of my  sleep so that i can show up throughout  my day  and excel be totally focused be totally  present have good energy be in a good  mood and all of that derives from sleep